- Le long des autoroutes,
dans les stades et même
sur les tramways, les Ontariens
sont bombardés de publicités
pour le pari sportif.
Un déferlement qui se remarqueee
la télévision.
- Join BET 365 now!
- Sur les chaînes sportives,
les publicités se multiplient.
Et le pari s'intègre
même à la couverture
de certains journalistes.
- Presented by BET 365...
- En avril, l'Ontario est
devenue la première province
à libéraliser le marché
des jeux de hasard en ligne.
Depuis, une vingtaine
d'exploitants ont ob
des permis.
"Ça a été plus gros que
ce à quoi on s'attendait
confie cette représentante
de la province.
"L'objectif de la
libéralisation était
de protéger les consommateurs",
explique Catherine Jarmain.
En ce qui concerne
les publicités, le gouvernement
ontarien promet d'avoir
les compagnies à l'oeil.
Mais il n'existe aucune limite
quant au nombre de publicités
qu'un opérateur peut diffuser.
"Les gens parient depuis
le début de l'humanité",
lance Shelly White.
Si elle voit d'un bon oeil
la légalisation du jeu,
elle s'inquiète de
la prolifération des publicités.
Cet expert est du même avis.
Jim Lawson évolue dans
le monde du pari sportif
depuis longtemps.
Le PDG des hippodromes Woodbine
veut aussi profite c c cette
révolution dans son industrie.
Une chose est sûre, la course
aux consommateurs est bien
lancée. Et les opérateurs se
bousculent pour avoir un morceau
du gâteau. Le marché du pari
sportif en Ontario est déjà
évalué à plus d'un milliard
de dollars, un chiffre qui
risque d'augmenter dans les
prochaines années, surtout si
les joueurs sont plus nombreux.
Ici Yasminedididi,
Radio-Canada, Toronto